new poll out from NPR and Marist showing
that not only is Trump leading the pack
on the primary side of things but he's
neck and neck with Biden nationally
Biden 47 Trump 46 so statistically a tie
it's a tough fact for the people making
the argument that Trump can't possibly
win a general election and also among
Independents Trump is leading by by a
lot according to NPR Marist obviously
not a right-wing poll Trump is up eight
points among Independents over Joe Biden
then you look at the Harvard Harris poll
Trump is currently leading Biden for
president by Five Points 45 to 40 and
among Independents Trump is leading
Biden by 18 points 45 to 27.
still you're going to hear this argument
from some people who prefer other
candidates they're going to say well
Trump just can't win the general
election sure he's dominating the
primary but he can't win a general
election what what is your evidence of
that